saturday was a double day at the st.
Louis classic as rounds three and four
were both contested in the stronger
group Grandmaster Anatoly Brodsky has
underperformed at only one win and three
losses in round three he beat Jake
climbing with black for me it was boring
most of the time isn't something
happened and when the fog disappeared he
was bad right here he blundered I see he
blundered exchange I actually don't know
here he blundered something here like
science bowling game if I would win
another one here I had some nice tactic
so hook takes Tito so if King takes
Bishop takes of six and h4 is handy I
can talk about this but this is like
half a minute you can say that this is
like nice miniature in the end this is
this is not bad by cook look takes g2
it's not bad because if kim takes bishop
and she talkin design in these standings
the color change indicates which
prospective Norma's can no longer do so
unlikely as it is keep in mind each can
still win the tournament in the IM
competition angelo young stumbled in the
third but resumed his winning way in the
fourth against Kavinsky with black i
managed to win a pawn in the middle game
but it's not enough to convert the win
so we have to still play keep on playing
and and it did he hit flag and here is
where I set a trap right here he play
route to g1 which is kind of force and
then I play nice
for and idea is take the bishop and
maybe play at five also I can also play
h6 attack the bishop another idea is
maybe Bishop d7 and then be pie so here
he made a mistake slight mistake keep
licking up to and now he falls into my
little trap here I want to pawn bishop
takes and if he captured the night then
I have Bishop takes and then roop be one
and then I just moved back and I think
this is better for block because of the
two bishop plus the extra point so here
he played the correct move Queen B 1 and
then I play night h5 g-49 up six I think
this is the best continuation if 97 I
don't see any possible place for my
night although it protects the rope but
there's no square so i did play Knight
up stick I thought this is easy win but
then he play rook see one false move and
I play Queen 83 I have to keep my queen
on a three so I stopped any Queen
maneuvers to be to attack the app sec so
i have to keep my queen I stopping any
Queen B to Quinn d3 idea so here it my
rookie won @midnight b7
eep I'm and here I'm running short of
time I don't know what to if I'm going
to capture if I'm going to move my knife
so I played the capture point exponent
politics pawn Knight b6 cm x aha x x
upon but my pieces is kind of tied up my
rope my dish no place to go so I'm
trying to open up my bishop maybe Bishop
d7 and move the book to summer d 8 or CA
so you play Queen so now I develop
Bishop 86 now this is the danger there
is a possible II e6 context and Queenie
pipe so this is my best shot to stop the
threat and here I have to do I don't
know I'm short of time I get like two
minutes and i think i have to give up
the exchange to stop any any possible
make one idea is he can play e cigs and
clean up stubborn Queen g7 may so yeah
here Queenie tree now i have also idea
like queen bee to check kingi three
Knight takes pawn Queenie 24 24 and
maybe Quincy or queen a three you can't
capture the night because of Queen takes
rook takes nine but i don't know i don't
have much time to calculate this
variation so i play
here I play I just took the Queen night
takes King v3 Bishop b5 and I completely
miss Kinney for which protect the night
and stop any discovery check with my
knife so I continued with night maybe I
need to get rid of possible passport I
play night there Bishop c4 okay be one
look up to so this is my chance to
remove all the points and 96 okay 295
and I think he simply mr. Rooke a pipe
and it King the four I have a bishop
takes Bishop takes pawn and I think love
is ok if not winning but here he play d6
trying to create a passport Roxy 537 and
now I was thinking maybe Bishop deep I'm
is ok here it group takes then I can
take care but I saw this a you can play
a king be 40 this is what I miss it can
be poor I can seem to take the point if
ye six I don't know maybe I have to
check here King pigs night here kini 5
and rook takes pawn maybe
erepublik I believe I got to pass porn
on both side but here I just simply
remove this pass porn group takes d7
King up seven and King before Bishop
e-cigs and he is this is where he
replied so I win the game if the
continuation blood kin why can play a
route takes pawn and then check King
Sadie three and then i can simply take
the g fool rook takes and I think luck
should win this game and the phrase of
the day in the IM section is business as
usual we'll see if the lower titled
players can break through this hierarchy
this tournament is developing quickly
sunday is yet another double day
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
view the games at us chess champs com
Oh